Haley Bieber full on channeling her
hubby Justin you betcha you betcha it's
an amazing feeling yeah the 26 year old
model goes full JB in a recent Tick Tock
lip syncing to a viral sound pulled from
this iconic carpool karaoke moment
immediately
like like instantly I was like yeah no
I'm telling you right now I see what I
needed to see and now Haley's embodying
her bow completely nailing the line
immediately well immediately no I'm
telling you right now I see what I
needed to see there's some tick tock
Trends writing in the caption from the
drafts this really is my mood 99 of the
time though yeah that's me looks like
Haley's been having lots of fun on Tick
Tock Lately from going cold plunging and
enjoying the sauna
to giving a glimpse inside her Sunday
cinnamon roll making routine
[Music]
and of course vacationing with Justin
and their closest friends
[Applause]
seems she's living life to the fullest
before the couple takes their next steps
last year A source told E.T the pair
dreams of having a big family someday
he's really funny we have a good time
he's just really sweet he's a good kid
he's a good part and uh I love him they
both know what great parents they are
going to be together adding that they
both feel like part of their reason for
being on Earth was to be parents it
means something to me